CBS News contributor Jody Cantor's of
correspondent at the New York Times her
colleagues broke the story of those
settlements with five women totaling
thirteen million dollars little over two
weeks ago Jody good morning good morning
last week people were saying this will
never happen he makes too much money the
viewers the the ratings are higher than
they've ever been
what do you think was a tipping point
because after that story the advertisers
dropped out well what my colleagues
Michael Schmidt and Emily still reported
is that women were continuing to come
forward last summer Fox said that
essentially it had cleaned house it had
solved these problems it was committed
to a different kind of culture but
they've known about these things known
about these charges and as recently as
yesterday another woman went on the
record to say that Bill O'Reilly had
made a comment about her showing more
cleavage who tried to sleep with her etc
etc so we don't know what will still
come out in the future you don't think
this is the end of the story there's
been a pretty steady stream of women
coming out of fox since last summer
talking about offensive things that both
Roger Ailes and Bill O'Reilly have said
and done do you think that this story
both in terms of Roger Ailes and in
terms of Bill O'Reilly will somehow
change the climate in which their
institution that harassment goes on and
women are not reporting I think it's
really clear that workplace culture has
changed that there's a much clearer
definition than there used to be 20
years ago 30 years ago during the I need
a health scandal for instance a lot of
people said oh it happens in the
workplace you should brush it off what
we're seeing now is a much more
professional culture in which there is
usually a common definition of what's
right and wrong what do you make of Bill
O'Reilly's responses charlie said at the
top of the broadcast it does seem very
defiant almost like he feels that he is
a victim here well that has been his
line all along but I think the question
for Fox is that that show does strike a
very moralistic tone he styles himself
look out right now that's a kind of
arbiter of values and yet what the
protesters were saying outside the Fox
building and in an airplane
up in the sky is they called him a
sexual predator that is a really tough
term for a brand to sustain your paper
reports that after news of these Bill
O'Reilly settlements which date all the
way back to 2004 that women at Fox News
quote questioned whether top executives
were serious about maintaining a culture
based on trust and respect was firing
him enough does it make sense for other
executives who are aware of these
settlements to remain so the question
about these settlements is that they
allow parties to come agreement to come
to agreement in private right a woman
who's been wronged a man who's been
accused they can reach a financial
settlement and void embarrassment and
trauma to them both but that means that
it doesn't serve the public function of
within a company or within the public at
large thing what's okay what's not okay
let's agree about how to treat Gretchen
each other in the workplace stretchin
Carlson set this whole thing in motion
because Roger Ailes was not going to
agree to give her a 2:00 p.m. show she
sued him she got paid twenty million
dollars but as part of that she signed a
confidentiality and she's still to this
day cannot talk about what happened for
legal teams now asking her to be
released from that and yet it's the
critical mass of women essentially
helping each other at Fox right one
woman coming forward after another and
now these executives speaking up and we
do see over and over again in these
situations that when women had a company
come together and say we don't feel safe
we don't feel respected here that's a
very powerful force was the straw that
broke the camel's back
hey the advertisers fleeing or Fox
executives worrying about the reputation
of their news channel this company was
being besieged on all sides by this
accusation thank you so much Judy thank
you